je viens vous vendre la France demain ah
bon c'est ça la France de demain non
France demain c'est moi
souvenez-vous bien de ce nom parce qu'il
y aura un avant il y en a un après
je vais créer un nouveau business vous
pourriez venir bosser avec moi non est
devenu un symbole de la réussite il
l'aime avant tout la notoriété et la
gloire tu me fais tout péter il faut aux
gens 10 feux d'artifice ou 10 feux de
Bengal il va falloir en plein la
vue
applaude
vous avez pas peur de tout gâcher en
ayant les yeux plus gros que le ventre
métier il faut avoir les yeux plus gros
que le ventre
ce niveau d'endettement c'est une bombe
nucléaire à retardement
[Musique]
que ce soit sur vous que tout ça retombe
tout bien tout petit détail je suis
indestructible
je vais vous raconter une histoire très
drôle l'histoire d'un petit gars de
banlieue qui se prenait pour un grand
révolutionnaire et qui en réalité
n'était qu'un tout petit vendeur de
tapis
tout ça c'est bien gentil mais c'est un
petit pas comment je deviens président
de la République
vous êtes devenu le roi de Marseille
qu'est-ce que c'est
quand tu veux gagner il y a les règles
il y a des petites zones de flou
les vrais gens sont pas dans un jeu
télévisé il prenait la politique pour
une chemise
qui toi
pub contre les élites parisiennes mais
c'est quoi ton idée c'est de mettre en
danger notre famille et tout ce qu'on a
construit
j'ai encore des choses à offrir à ce
pays
bien que si un jour vous deviez aller en
prison ce n'est pas vous c'est tapis
c'est le mythe
c'est le rêve
[Musique]